et jeudi dernier se dérouler des
élections internes à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
élections pour renouveler les membres du
conseil d'administration et des
différentes commissions recherche ou
encore villes universitaires enseignants
chercheurs devaient se prononcer sur des
listes et celle portée par le président
sortant jean luc les sierre ne décroche
que 20 sièges sur un total de 71 celle
soutenue par son principal opposant
didier guillemot arrive en tête avec 34
sièges ballottage défavorable donc pour
le président sortant même si rien n'est
encore fait car les étudiants aussi se
sont prononcés dans d'autres commissions
et pour désigner le 10 mai le nouveau
chef de file de l'université il faudra
donc les rassembler on écoute tout de
suite didier mau par téléphone
il ya une vraie envie de la communauté
universitaire d'aller de l'avant
voilà c'est à dire que nous avons fait
campagne sur un projet pas du tout sur
un rejet
et ce projet qui est clair remporter
l'adhésion je pense que c'est ça qu'on
peut dire à l'issue du scrutin nous
avons fait une campagne transparente sur
un projet avec l'idée de rassembler et
maintenant il va nous falloir rassembler
au delà des différentes listes
parce que c'est de l'université dont il
s'agit et ce travail commence dès
aujourd'hui
et je précise que le président sortant
jean-luc décerne en revanche pas encore
réagi à ces résultats malgré nos
demandes d'interview